Harman soldin avait 32 ans le
journaliste de l'AFP est mort sous des
tirs de roquette russe dans les environs
de châssifiard à quelques kilomètres de
bar Mount de Paris à Washington les
hommages se multiplient
avec courage dès les premières heures du
conflit il était au front pour rétablir
les faits pour nous informer
pour la porte-parole de la Maison
Blanche Karine Jean-Pierre le monde a
une dette envers Harman soldin comme
envers les dix autres employés de médias
tués en Ukraine depuis février 2022
au moment de l'attaque Harman soldin
n'était en compagnie de quatre collègues
tous indemne ce n'est pas la première
fois que le journaliste se retrouvait au
milieu d'affrontement déjà présent au
tout premier jour de l'invasion en
Ukraine il se rendait très régulièrement
sur le front comme lors de ce reportage
tourner au début du mois de mai
[Musique]
dans un tweet le journaliste français né
à Sarajevo avait fait part de la terreur
qu'il avait ressenti être pris sous une
pluie de thierrière avec un groupe qui
creusait des tranchées et probablement
l'une des pires choses que j'ai vécues
depuis que je suis en Ukraine avec des
roquettes qui explosent à moins de 50
mètres pure terreur la directrice Europe
de l'AFP a rendu hommage à un
journaliste débordant d'énergie qui
était selon elle toujours prêt à partir
y compris dans les zones les plus
difficiles